what I want to do in this video see if
we can find the measure of angle D if we
could find the measure of angle D and
like always pause this video and see if
you can figure it out and I'll give you
a little bit of a hint it'll involve
thinking about how an inscribed angle
relates to the corresponding to the
measure of the arc that it intercepts so
think about it like that
alright so let's work on this a little
bit so what do we know what do we know
well angle D angle D intercepts an arc
it intercepts
this fairly large arc that I'm going to
highlight right now in this purple color
so it intercepts that arc we don't know
the measure of that arc or at least we
don't know the measure of that arc yet
if we did know the measure of this arc
that I'm highlighting then we know that
the measure of angle D would just be
half that because the measure of an
inscribed angle is half the measure of
the arc that it intercepts we've seen
that multiple times so if we knew the
measure of this arc we would be able to
figure out what the measure of angle D
is but we do know we don't know the
measure of that arc but we do know the
measure of another arc we do know the
measure of the arc that completes the
circle so we do know the measure of this
arc you might be saying hey wait how do
we know that measure it's not labeled
well the reason why we know the measure
of this arc that I've just highlighted
in this teal color is because the
inscribed angle that intercepts it they
gave us the information they said this
is a 45 degree angle so this is a 45
degree angle then this over here is a 90
degree 90 degree arc the measure of this
arc is 90 degrees the measure of Arc I
guess you could say this is a measure of
Arc I'm ready this way the measure of
Arc WL WL is equal to 90 degrees it's
twice that the inscribed angle that
intercepts it now why is that helpful
well if you go all the way around the
circle you're 360 degrees so this
this purple Ark that we cared about that
we said hey if we could figure out the
measure of that we're gonna be able to
figure out the measure of angle D and
that Plus met arc WL they are going to
add up to 360 degrees let me write that
down so the measure the measure of Arc
let's see and this is going to be this
is going to be a major arc right over
here this is so L I W the measure of Arc
L I W the measure of Arc W L plus the
measure of Arc WL Plus this right over
here that's going to be equal to 360
degrees this is going to be equal to 360
degrees now we already know that this is
90 degrees we already know W L is 90
degrees so if you subtract 90 degrees
from both sides you get that the measure
of this large arc right over here a
measure of Arc L i w is going to be
equal to 270 degrees I just took 300 I
went all the way around the circle I
subtracted out this 90 degrees and I'm
left with 270 degrees so let me write
that down this is the measure of this
arc and purple is 270 degrees and now we
can figure out the measure of angle D
it's an inscribed angle that intercepts
that arc so it's going to have half the
measure of the angles going to have half
the measure so half of 270 is 135
degrees and we're done and you might
notice something interesting that if you
add 135 degrees plus 45 degrees that
they add up to 180 degrees so it looks
like at least for this case that these
angles these opposite angles of this
inscribed quadrilateral it looks like
they are it looks like they are
supplementary so an interesting question
is are they always going to be
supplementary if you have a
quadrilateral an arbitrary quadrilateral
inscribed in a circle so each of the
vertices of the quadrilateral sit on the
circle if you have that
our opposite angles of that
quadrilateral are they always
supplementary do they always add up to
180 degrees so I encourage you to think
about that and even prove it if you get
a chance and the proof is very close to
what we just did here in order to prove
it you just have to do it with more
general numbers like you know instead of
saying 45 degrees you could call this X
and then you would want to prove that
this right over here is wouldn't have to
be 180 minus X so I encourage you to do
that on your own but I'm gonna do it in
a video as well so you can check if our
reasoning is similar